it's a flavor explosion and it's the
perfect go to much it's gonna make you
so happy once you take one bite out of
this sandwich hi my name is Hitomi and
today for Women's History Month we'll be
making my mom's chicken katsu sandwich I
chose to make this recipe for Women's
History Month in honor of my mom because
she took a big risk in coming to the
States and it represents you know her
Japanese culture as well as kind of
adapting to the new American lifestyle
this sandwich is really good it has all
the textures you want it's got the
crunch it's super juicy it has the right
amount of sweet and a little bit of a
Tang from the sauce we're using chicken
thigh because it's a lot juicier just
flip it over and take your knife and
then just slice in there and flatten it
out so everything becomes an even
thickness my mom made chicken katsu
sandwich for me pretty often growing up
because it is cheap it is quick to make
and it's something that you can make a
bunch of the night before I looked up to
my mom and her finance skills she was a
great budgeter she knew how to apply in
our daily lives as well as her meals
because obviously she had to feed us
every day please please if you're gonna
make this use Japanese breadcrumbs and
you can use it their mom order for it
but if you don't have a thermometer the
trick I use is just get some of that
panko crumb
drop it in the hot oil if it sizzles and
floats immediately it's ready for a
frying so once the chicken is done set
it aside on a sheet of paper towel this
will absorb the excess oil there's two
key ingredients to this Mayo sauce the
Japanese Mayo or QP Mayo and hot mustard
and depending on how spicy you want it
you could go more you could go less so
I'm just gonna dabble dabble here much
and then we're gonna get our beautiful
Japanese toast and let's spread the
sauce on each slice so my mom moved in
her late 20s when she married my dad she
gave everything up she left everybody
behind and kind of decided to go on this
adventure with my dad which is something
I really look up to so her moving
and coming to the States has inspired me
a lot for whether it's career choices or
you know even moving from place to place
it's kind of like if she could do it I
could do it so I really look up to that
like how beautiful this sandwiches I
could probably eat this whole thing I
don't even need to cut it but just so I
could show you how beautiful it is
inside let's slice it in half it's just
so beautiful it's so tasty it's gonna
make you so happy once you take one bite
out of this sandwich so I'm super
excited to eat this it looks delicious
I know it's delicious so eat that can
last no bug I've been waiting all day my
mom's gonna be so proud of me oh yes